[Musique]
moi dans ma vie la chance d'occuper des
postes sportivité crète où et quand vous
occupez vous êtes devant déjà gelé vous
êtes responsable des effets on dit bien
que les succès vont beaucoup de papas
les frissons reprenait une somme a au
final vous êtes de perdre les échelons
dames et d'échecs à laçage donc à partir
de ce moment il faut faire en sorte que
l'on réussisse
parce que voir la passion de
l'excellence c'est toujours bien faire
surtout envie de faire des sous qui ont
tenu des résultats
et pour ce faire nous premier pas c'est
de définir une vision de savoir ce qu'on
veut et 2 d'être prêt à tout faire
l'amour où aller pour obtenir son but de
définir une vision
dit comme ça c'est facile les
éléphanteaux si je me souviens à 2011
j'ai été nommé comme revêtement spécial
adjoint et du président de l'union
africaine et du sénat saugy je devais
être d'humeur deux énormes mission de
maintien de la paix plus grands saumons
1 milliard 400 millions de dollars de
budget 28 fonctionnaires dans la
personne qui devait être qui devait être
montré un doigt le chef de cabinet il
vient nous rencontrer ville de 10,6
fille madame dites moi comment vous
aussi je vous pouvez arriver à 2 les
transnationales
comme dit sénèque il n'y a pas de vent
favorable à kiel de c3i va encore vous
utilisez la vision et que vous êtes en
face de quelqu'un qui est du même avis
l'échec est en fait lui s'il l'a fait
que tout simplement pour me déstabiliser
parce que j'étais la première à lille i
des matchs où il a souffert des horreurs
raison de ne pas alors ce qu'il ya c'est
que le site du poids dames et votre
master il ya une chose qui a toujours
guidé ma vie j'ai vu peut-être la chance
ou la malchance la première femme
africaine à la télévision et de la faire
mais imaginez si je me disais je viens à
tous les deux à vous autres médiateurs
ou des enfants qui venaient rappeler
donc il faut voir la mer il faut faire
un saut au minimum les utilisent
mais la vision toute seule ne suffit pas
car vous avez des rues ni la vision
rechercher les sénat qui devait la belle
manière naturelle et même à neuf la
vision pour la beta 9 vous avez besoin
d'une équipe pour vous devez motivés et
pour moitié de votre équipe vous devez
vous devez faire en sorte que
l'environnement de travail ne soient pas
toxique
[Applaudissements]
soyez compétents pourquoi être jeune et
compétent et rencontres si vous êtes en
pétard vous êtes capable de comprendre
les autres et les autres aussi vous ai
fait le plus important il faut respecter
la loi et le respect numéro un nouveau
collaborateur c'est déjà notre île
apport shalit et du vent c'est la vertu
des places vous êtes alors que vous
provoquer une réunion à nogent à 20h44
vous est là et je les fais tout ce
qu'ils ont travaillé avec moi je suis
une manière de la populaire aujourd'hui
le voc à 20h55 soit du sud
donc je dis ça m'est arrivé dans ma vie
de nos idées que nous convoquent des
réunions que j'arrivais qui les
personnes dans la salle je m'assois et
je suis le chef de vous donner tout ce
qu'il faut on ne peut pas oublier ce que
malgré tout l'excellent ans quand vous
êtes en position de dj set il faut
décider
le moment bien toujours où il faudra des
décisions et il faut réaliser que je me
souviens que nous avons été dans un
village pour régler des questions les
problèmes communautaires
les communautés se battaient elle
n'arrivait pas à sa fin et nous nous
trouvons c'était de venir essayer de
comprendre quelle était de convier ai-je
pourquoi il se battait comme un
déménagement
donc nous arrivons à 8 heures du matin
nous ne somme toute la journée
pratiquer sans manger sans voix de
profitations à 17 heures au moment où
tout le monde s'est un peu calmée et au
moment où tous deux villages accepté de
mieux sur la place publique et j'en
insiste me glisse adoré que madame la
sécurité dis qu'il faut pas pris les
visiteurs parce que les avions ne
bronche pas à briser toute mon histoire
ma place si vous partez vous prenez la
poudre d'escampette
ça veut dire que vous donnez le message
aux populations que de sécurité est plus
important que nos problèmes mais pire
c'est que quand vous allez l'aimer parce
que de toutes les façons vous êtes
obligés de nous venir pour régler le
problème
vous partez pas parce que vous avez
perdu votre revenu et bien figurez-vous
à générer du papier vous préparé avec
nous attelons nous sommes restés jusqu'à
23 heures
nous avons créé la réunion nous avons
des nouveautés et de la passion de
l'excellence la passion de l'excellence
ne va pas de soi seize vraiment beaucoup
de ces beaucoup de 2,2 de pouvoir se
soit même beaucoup de contrôles des et
beaucoup de problèmes
j'ai les a faites depuis hier j'ai
entendu quelques années de souffrance
moi je les appelle des défis les défis
premièrement c'est que c'est sa création
ce chef de table finale agri pas excusez
moi roger d'appel en a même deux
donc il faut gérer des emmerdes comme
vous travaillez il ya toujours des gens
pour ça il faut digérer et choisir la
bataille que vous vous démenez si vous
suivez et qui vous vers le temps et
après vous allez dans la brousse et
n'hésitez pas si vous êtes modifier les
zones isolées vainqueur mais il y a
aussi toute une série de contraintes qui
sont plus ou moins liés à la vie de tous
les jours quand je me souviens quand
j'étais ministre
un jour j'ai été appelé par là samedi
j'étais pas là on me dit est survenu je
suis venu à la sandero me dit mais
madame vous ne respectez pas des
institutions vous allez bien vous êtes
les situations plus tard alors mardi aux
députés
messieurs les députés en juriste et je
fais partie de ceux qui ont apporté la
démocratie au niger je veux parler de
ceux qui auront mis en place la société
civile mw d'ici ne soit quelque chose à
vous dire
exemple tout simple je suis rentré un
jour chez moi je rentre à la maison le
matin
j'appelle une fois une nouvelle voie
donc dans la maison que je ne
connaissais pas et je dis est ce que je
vous demande si vous avez de la vie
humaine au nom notamment du mécénat
éminents services
là j'ai bien dormi s'il avait 11 donc
mon fils pendant que je faisais de
travail pour le niger avec lundi il
avait dépassé par la puberté savoie a
nui bien des passions pas toujours
évident mais moi je n'ai pas mon pays si
c'était à recommencer pour moi c'est
savoir ce qu'on veut c'est être prêt à
se battre pour obtenir ce qu'on veut
c'est se battre jusqu'au martyre
et quand on dit il faut se battre ni
secondes
on est prêt à affronter tout et puis
avant de la capacité
évaluer ses réalisations à son organise
quelque chose sur la base date qu'on
pose sur la base des profits mais mieux
je parle de compte neuf sans complexe
c'est il faut être compétent si vous
n'êtes pas compétents
quel besoin ce que vous voulez pas ya un
point et d'amour pour laisser comme ça
on sait faire on ne sait pas faire
et il ya aussi la question de la
satisfaction les applications de la
satisfaction du travail bien fait vous
le voyez vous même vous de voir si les
gens pouvaient parler nous voyais tous
les gens avec une mauvaise
donc mesdames et messieurs ma passion
d'être vous comprenez après avoir écouté
que j'ai une profonde aversion pour la
vidéo et la passion de l'excellence ma
passion de l'excellence gagnera généraux
et messieurs je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]